l'un des principaux sujets de débats
portaient sur la situation de cette
centrale nucléaire de zappos ridge et
l'un de ses bâtiments étaient touchés
hier par un incendie en raison des
combats la russie nie l'avoir visé
accusant des sabotages ukrainien des
mercenaires argument rejeté par
l'ukraine et ses soutiens pour eux cette
attaque sur la centrale constitue une
menace pour le monde à new york fanny
chauffin
ce conseil de sécurité a vu s'opposer
deux versions des faits avec d'un côté
les occidentaux qui dénoncent les
bombardements russes sur la centrale
nucléaire de zappos ridja avec les états
unis qui condamne une attaque dangereuse
et irresponsable qui menace l'europe et
le reste du monde d'un autre côté il y à
leurs représentants russes présents
autour de la table de ce conseil de
sécurité il nie toute implication de la
russie dans cet incendie et rejette la
faute sur les nationalistes ukrainiens
ils dénoncent l' hystérie artificiel je
cite de kiev et la campagne de mensonges
et de désinformation 1 contre la russie
la russie qui se retrouve isolé sur la
scène internationale et mis au banc des
accusés pour ces bombardements il y
avait aussi lors de ce conseil de
sécurité le directeur de l'agencé
internationale de l'énergie atomique
il s'est exprimé il a écarté tout danger
mais la situation reste confuse sur
place il a demandé l'autorisation à la
russie et à l'ukraine d'envoyer un
convoi d'experts sur le site de
tchernobyl pour lui il est temps d'agir
cas la situation est inédite c'est la
première fois dans l'histoire qu'un
conflit militaire a lieu près d'un site
nucléaire